los líderes de la otan cierran su último
día de cumbre centrada sobre todo en
amenazas como por ejemplo el terrorismo
especialmente en la zona sur de la
alianza una cuestión de especial
importancia sobre todo para países como
españa y francia por la proximidad
geográfica que tienen con amenazas que
provienen sobre todo de la zona del
sahel por ello se va a centrar una
colaboración con países socios como por
ejemplo mauritania la mayoría de líderes
coinciden en que es importante poder
vigilar y también cooperar con estos
socios también del sur para poder
vigilar el flanco sur a pesar de que
ahora mismo la amenaza más directa y más
importante para la seguridad de la otan
es rusia así lo declararon ayer los
líderes con esta cumbre se cierra una de
las reuniones más importantes y más
clave de la historia de la organización
con más soldados ampliación de la
frontera con rusia con el próximo
ingreso de suecia de finlandia como
miembros también más armas y más
presencia de estados que nunca